ご視聴ありがとうございました
中央トヨテミの恋人、驚異的な月の持ち主、千葉県出身
ローン、ついそ100万だ
このボケ、なんでここでそんなパイが出てくんだよ
ああ、最後はヤツの逆転ホームランかよ。
じんとぐ、じんとぐだよー。
はい、行こ、行こ。
行くべ。
たしかに、このままじゃダメだわ。
な、なんだ
おい、豊臣、俺だよ俺、明智くんでーす
あげろよ、いるんだろ、おとなしく出てこい
ご近所の皆さん 豊臣くんは燃えるゴミの日に
嫌な奴が来ちゃったな
そういう人なんですよ
おう 遊びに来てやったぞ
こんにちは ああ こんばんはか
いや 誰?
俺の彼女のリエ
よろしく
あなたが麻雀超うまいって有名な豊臣くん?
そうそうそう 麻雀超うまい豊臣くんだ
あたし、麻雀強い人好き。
そ、そう?
だから、あたし、こうちゃん大好きなの。
びよびよ。
何しに来てん!
くしゃ、どっか行ってんな。
誰?やすくん?
あの野郎、また一人でカラオケでも行ってんだろ。
孤独ね。あの人も全然女の子にモテそうもないものね。
誰がモテねって?
やーだ、急にアップで出てこないでよ
出てくるメンツは決まってんべ、安心してくで
誰?
俺の恋人のめぐみだ、めぐめぐって呼んでくで
こんにちは
何がそんなにおかしいんだ、恋人だって
どう見たってお前に似合わねえよ
まあ、オラの方がちっといい男だから
もう、やくんたら
何しに来てん
よう、みんな楽しそうにやってるね
あ、慎太郎
今、電話してたんだ
まあ、汚ねえところだけど、上がってくれ
僕んちだぞ
はーい
なんでアキナちゃんが慎太郎と一緒に
よう、アキナちゃんどうしたの?慎太郎なんかと一緒に
だな
出てくるメンツは決まってんべ、安心してくで
そりゃ安のセリフだよ、なんで一緒なんだ
やだ、男の嫉妬はみっともないよ
一気に場を盛り下げんなよな
気にしない、気にしない。世界は一家、人類は友を呼ぶってね。
あんだそりゃ。
ま、やることだけはさっさとやろうがね。
やっくん、しっかり。
れへへ、まかせるだ。
こうちゃん、まけないで。
ざつらい。
がんばってね。
おう。
あったりまえよ。まあ、見てなって。
あきだちゃんが、おだのとなりにすわった。
バカな!
どうして?
どうして僕の隣に来てくれないんだ、アキナちゃん?
僕のことなんか、もうどうでもいいって言うのか?
バカヤロウ!
ウィッチ!
おい、お前の番だぞ。
トヨトミ。
いけない!今は勝負に専念しなくては!
よーし!三色イーシャンテンだ!
ここは一発勝負!現物のドラチーソー落としだ!
よーし!いい引きだ!
二瞬目ドラ斬りだ!これはないな!
よーし!追っかけり!
追っかけに行くし!
ローン!
メンピン純ちゃん!
三色ドライシー!
バイマン!
どうだ?
あー、すっごい!
さすがこうちゃんだから好きよ!
いや、軽い軽い
どうしちゃう?
つかー
あ、ダメじゃない、豊臣くん、うっちゃん
あ、アキナちゃん!
やっぱりアキナちゃんは僕の味方なんだ!
りゃんぴんつむではねまわったのにね。
おったくだよ。
ぼくだってしょうぶてだったんだよ。
うっそ。どらきって?
いいのよ。みえはらなくたって。
しんようしてもくれない。
ねえ、役も上がって?
何、小さいこと言ってるだ
俺はメグメグのためにトップ取ってプレゼントしてやるからよ
わあ、本当?嬉しいわ
信じて待ってるだぞ
うん、待ってる
信用だ
愛する二人は強い信頼関係で結ばれている
なのに僕たちはもう
そうだね、そうそう、そうよね
お客さん、東京から来ましただが
まあね、東京が俺のふるさとさ
ふるさとは遠きにありて思うもの
近くて東京は男女の中ってね
え、めぐめぐが見てると手がいいな
嘘ばっかり
シロ
ハク
バニュはウーワン2枚、パーワン1枚か。
ハクを泣いてもマンガン止まり。
コーヒーじゃつまらんし。
やったー!
フランス料理だっぺー。
ホント?
ここは一発。
ビジだ!
テンパった!
234の三色スミレブロー。
しかし、Q1は強い。
回すか。
いな、こういう逆境に打ち勝ってこそ、日本男児、いざ、ゆかーん!
リーチ、ローンパー!
リーチ一発、ダブトンホイッツイッツ、バイムワンワンワン、ダベッシー!
すっごーい!統計しちゃおう!
くそー、明智奴ともに敗漫か
慎太郎さんも、敗漫がんなきゃ苦しいわね
慎太郎さん?
確か前まで秋名ちゃんが慎太郎を呼ぶときは慎太郎くんだったのに
いつからさんづけに変わったんだ
ごめんね豊臣くんやっぱり私麻雀強い人のほうが
まあそういうことだわ
慎太郎そ、どんな
私もう自分の気持ちに嘘がつけないさようなら
秋名ちゃん
あははは!
こいつ、さっきから変だぞ。
ベニテングだけでもくらったか?水玉のやつさ。
ほらほら、そんなやつかまってる場合じゃないよ。
ほれ、リーチ!
はっ!
いやいやいや、楽しいよね。
振り込まん。
明智がトップ取ろうが安川がろうが僕の知ったこっちゃない
だがしかし今日だけは
今日だけは絶対に
慎太郎だけには死んでも
クリートマーク
ついに織田に対して逆恨みの復讐宣言をぶっつけた豊臣
果たして秋名は本当に織田に乗り換えてしまったのであろうか
リーチ
すごいしんたろうさんまだ6巡目よ
なに普通だよ
あきなちゃんがあおだのリーチを喜ぶなんて
くそ絶対しんたろうのやつには振り込まんぞ
やったたんやおてんぱい
小さな数字だ
しかし慎太郎は4、6、8のメンツから平気で4を横にしてくる男だ
おりだ
硬いなあ、そういうの
硬いマージャンなんち
硬い
しかしその硬さが裏目に出ることだって
あるぜ
リーチ一発
ツモ初三眼光
ハネマン!
すごいじゃない!シンタロウさん!
何がおかしいんだ?
言っただろ!シンタロウには絶対振り込まないって!
僕は一発で掴んだ!
チーソーを当たり牌と呼んで止めたんだぜ!
それで勝ち誇ったつもりか、トヨトミ?
おめえがそのパイを切ったら、リーチ一発だけだったんだ!
それをがらにもなく止めたりしやがって!
かちくしょう!
おめえのせいでハネマン積もられたぜ!
ねえ、か、考えなし!
バカたれが!
トヨタに…
何本だめ持っとくよ!
ねえ、かわいそうよ。あんまりいじめないで。
まあ、リエがそういうんなら?
やっくん、いいじゃない、そのへんで。まだ勝ってるんだし。
それもそうだな
さて、これからまくるぜ
頑張ってね、慎太郎さん
そうだ、何を考えてるんだ僕は
慎太郎のやつをまかさなければ何にもならないじゃないか
降りてたらダメなんだ、振り込んだっていい
気合い負けちゃいけない
立ち向かって行かなきゃ
ドラはパーピン
ふんふん、ふんふん。
んあああああ!
あんだ?
どうした?
いや、別に、ハイパイが悪かったもんだから。
あんだ、そうか。とりあえず、いいこったな。
いや、困った。なんてひどいハイパイなんだ。
なんつう不自然な奴。
ツモは悪いし勝てっこないよな
やったぜ
四巡目転廃
タイヤを三色ドラドラ
こいつはいただきだぜ
ここは非テレパシー攻撃
ジャングーパーソーだぜ
ジャングーパーソー
リーチ
リーチだよリーチ
嫌な予感
人生なるようになるわさ
こっちはお昔からだまはってんだ
リーチでまったけ泥棒
通った
いつはミラクル、奇跡だ。
ちょっとは運がこっちへ回ってきたようだ。
見てるかい、アキナちゃん。
僕もまんざら捨てたもんじゃないってことを教えてやるよ。
ギャンウーパスをつかめ!
やったー!やったー!やったー!
わー!ついに慎太郎から一発で当たったー!やったー!やったー!やったー!
ほいほいほいほい!嬉しいよー!マンションが出て良かったよー!
泣かせるな。
ああ。
笑い泣きしてるの?
違うよ。やっぱ他人同士の振り込みはいつ見てもええもんだなと思ってよ。
たく、心が洗われるぜ。
それでは皆さん、お待たせいたしました。
今から私の手を開かせていただきます。
待ってます。
エド、エド、エド、エド。
そーれ、めんたっぴん、一発三食、ドラドラ、
バンバン、チャンチャン、スカスカ、ウィンビン、
ドッコイショ、そーれ、サックサクと。
サクッと!
トニー、参ったよなぁ
ついてないわよねぇ
ど低め、ツモだもん
リーチ一発ツモ、ウラウラ満岩
なんだ、積もってたの?
ああ、素敵だわ
スカンポの花がこんなにたくさん
トヨトミは死んだ
しかし彼の死んだ後には美しい花々が咲き乱れていた
ほら、まだ勝負は終わってないのよ
死ぬんだったら半ちゃん終わってからにしてよね
いつかー
ウォーン!
一通ドラ一五千二百
めんほんちえたい
ウォーン!
めんたい一発!
ドラやつのって三倍も!
ウォーン!
エンジンピーフ一平方倍も!
ほんろうといとい
三色三眼光シロ ドラさん
みなさん、サンバイバン!
トヨトミ君、さっきから振ってばっかり。
よっぽどついてないのね。一回も上がってないもの。
トヨトミ君、本当はうまいんでしょ?
今日はちょっと調子悪いのよね。
よっしゃ!ほっといてくれよ!
僕だって、振りたくて振ってるんじゃない!
負けたくて負けてるわけじゃない!
ただ、ただ、当たり羽を掴んじまうだけなんだよ、もう!
豊臣くん、かわいそう。
私がなんとかしてあげなくっちゃ。
豊臣くん、リエが応援してあげるね。
レゴがついててあげる。
え?えへへへへへ。
あ、あんた?あ、ちょっと、リエ。
あら、いいてね。
やればできるじゃない。
え、え、えへへへへへ。ちょ、ちょ、え、えへへへ。
キャー。いいツボしてるじゃない。
キキ強い。ね、リーチかけちゃお。リーチ。
え?で、でも、この手はチーピンを切ってまわす手じゃ。
大丈夫。大丈夫。ぜんぜん平気。スーピン切ってリーチよ。
じゃあ、リーチ。
み、みっともないわ。
男が麻雀で負けたぐらいでわーわー泣いて女の子に同情されて
その上自分の主張も通せず言いなりになるなんてみっともないと思う
あらそれだけ豊臣くんが純粋だってことよ
そうそう男だって泣きたいときには泣くものよ
慎太郎さん私と代わって
お願い
ああ
あ、強い
リーチ
つもり
ローン
リーチ一発メンチン一通ドライチスタンバイマン
私シーラナイト
私も
そ、そんな
見てみてシンタロウさん
早見えらい
メグメグ、結局こんだけしか勝てなかっただ、許してくんろ?
ううん、そんなことない。ヤッコン頑張ってくれたもの、うれしい。
メグメグ、優しい。
まあ、十分遊んだし、そろそろ帰るか。
楽しかったわ。あんなの見たの初めて。
明日はディズニーランドでも行こうか。
ほんと?やったー!
トヨタミ、じゃあなー。
スカンポ
とうとうアキナに見捨てられてしまったトヨトミ
アキナがトヨトミのもとへ戻ってくることはもうないのであろうか
果たしてアキナの本心はいかに
スカンポの花はただただ黙って咲いているのでありました
次回 幸をご期待
雪国の港町 そこにもひっそりとジャンソーはあった
ジャンソー 北のボタン そしてそこにも人生があった
次回 旅打ち図鑑 パート1 パート2 きっと見てね
眠っちゃいやっ
戦国の番の夢が湧く
雲風天空と理想が来る
飛べてくるんだ 対面者
つかんと 行かねばならぬのだ
リッチバッティングリッチ
しぼちゃかんちゃばじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら 情けもよほど狙い撃ち
君が挙げば 素敵じゃないか
僕とワンガンつぼろうよ
つかんと 幸せつかもうぞ
スーパースタート
嫌いで嫌いのまんまくところを 飛んで
嫌いだ 嫌いだ
さあ 行くの
はぁ
いつもここは三面町どころ
行くべかんきゃ
徳島そこの国籍が派だ
相撲にボーバー健康にやりづいて
買って飲み干すビールがうまい
スカッと
お酒はいどっちがけ
ご視聴ありがとうございました